MEXICO ABOUT THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS DISCOVERED IN HIS
PRIVATE OFFICE IN WASHINGTON.
HE DIDN'T ANSWER ANY OF THOSE.
A SOURCE TELLS CNN'S JAMIE
GANGEL THAT TEN DOCUMENTS WITH
CLASSIFICATION MARKINGS WERE
FOUND IN NOVEMBER, LESS THAN A
WEEK BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
THE PAPERS WERE DATED FROM 2013
TO 2016 WHEN BIDEN WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> NOW, THE SOURCE ALSO SAYS
THAT AMONG THE CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS WERE U.S. INTELLIGENCE
MEMOS AND BRIEFING MATERIALS
RELATED TO UKRAINE, IRAN, AND
THE UNITED KINGDOM.
CNN'S SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT
JAMIE GANGEL IS HERE.
JAMIE, YOU'VE GOTTEN GREAT
REPORTING.
YOU'VE ALSO LEARNED HOW THESE
DOCUMENTS WERE DISCOVERED.
SO JUST WALK US THROUGH THAT.
>> BIG PICTURE FOR CONTEXT, I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO STATE
THAT ALMOST ALL THE PAPERS IN
THE OFFICE WERE PERSONAL.
THEY INCLUDED MATERIALS ABOUT
BEAU BIDEN'S FUNERAL
ARRANGEMENTS, CONDOLENCE
LETTERS, REFERENCE MATERIAL.
IN FACT, THAT'S WHY A PERSONAL
LAWYER TO BIDEN WAS GOING
THROUGH THE MATERIAL AND
CLEANING IT OUT, SO THAT IT
WOULD REMAIN CONFIDENTIAL.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE LAWYER
IS GOING THROUGH THE BOXES, HE
SEES A MANILA ENVELOPE MARKED,
STAMPED ON THE FRONT "VP
PERSONAL," WHICH MAY EXPLAIN HOW
IT GOT PACKED UP.
HE OPENS IT UP.
HE SEES CLASSIFIED.
IMMEDIATELY CLOSES THE FOLDER
AGAIN AND CALLS FOR HELP.
THE ARCHIVES ARE INFORMED THAT
DAY, IMMEDIATELY.
THEY COME THE NEXT DAY TO PICK
UP THE THREE OR FOUR BOXES.
AND IN THOSE BOXES -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WHEN THE
ARCHIVES COME TO THE OFFICE THEY
SORT OF OF LOOK AROUND, DO A
CURSORY CHECK.
THEY IDENTIFY THREE OR FOUR
BOXES THAT CONTAIN THESE TEN
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AS WELL AS
SOME UNCLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT
FALL UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT.
>> JAMIE, ANY INDICATION ABOUT
HOW THESE DOCUMENTS GOT INTO
THIS OFFICE?
>> NO.
NOT THAT WE KNOW YET.
BUT YOU KNOW, MAYBE THE MARKING
ON THAT FOLDER.
MAYBE IT WAS AN HONEST MISTAKE
BECAUSE IT WAS MARKED VP
PERSONAL.
JUST FOR CON TX, I'VE SPOKEN TO
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THIS HAS
HAPPENED IN THE PAST.
FORMER PRESIDENTS, FORMER VICE
PRESIDENTS, FORMER HIGH-LEVEL
OFFICIALS ACCIDENTALLY TAKE
SOMETHING.
IT'S AN HONEST MISTAKE.
THEY ALSO POINT TO -- I SPOKE TO
ONE SOURCE WHO FOR THE RECORD IS
A LIFELONG REGISTERED
REPUBLICAN.
AND THAT SOURCE SAID TO ME THAT
THIS LOOKS LIKE AN HONEST
MISTAKE AND POINTED TO THE FACT
THAT THE BIDEN FOLKS IMMEDIATELY
COOPERATED AND RETURNED IT.
>> JAMIE GANGEL WITH THE
REPORTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S TURN NOW TO CNN'S SENIOR
LEGAL ANALYST ELIE HONIG.
LET'S START WITH BREAKING DOWN
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THESE
DOCUMENTS SO FAR.
AND OF COURSE WE'VE JUST BEEN
THROUGH THIS WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HOW THEY
COMPARE TO THE DOCUMENTS FOUND
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
>> SURE, VICTOR.
SO LET'S UNDERSTAND, FIRST OF
ALL, HOW DID WE GET HERE?
NOW, JOE BIDEN OF COURSE LEFT
OFFICE AS VICE PRESIDENT BACK IN
JANUARY OF 2017.
AFTER THAT HE TOOK A POSITION
WITH SOMETHING CALLED THE BIDEN
CENTER AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
IT WAS MOSTLY AN HONORLY
ACADEMIC TYPE OF TITLE.
NOW, HE HAD AN OFFICE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. WHICH HE LEFT
IN 2019.
JOE BIDEN LEFT, BUT HIS STUFF
STAYED BEHIND.
AND NOW, JUST TWO MONTHS AGO, IN
NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR, JOE
BIDEN'S ATTORNEYS WERE GOING
THROUGH THOSE DOCUMENTS AND THEY
FOUND SOME OF THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
NOW, THERE ARE SOME VITAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE BIDEN
DOCUMENTS AND DONALD TRUMP'S
DOCUMENTS, STARTING WITH THE
SHEER NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS.
AS JAMIE JUST REPORTED, TEN
DOCUMENTS FOUND IN BIDEN'S
OFFICE.
OVER 200 CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
FOUND AT MAR-A-LAGO.
ALSO, THE CLASSIFICATION LEVEL.
NOW, THIS IS ACTUALLY THE SAME.
BOTH HE JOE BIDEN AND DONALD
TRUMP'S DOCUMENTS INCLUDED
DOCUMENTS AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF CLASSIFICATION, WHAT WE CALL
SCI SENSITIVE COMPARTMENTED
INFORMATION.
NOW, THIS IS WHAT IN A
PROSECUTOR'S VIEW IS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT DIFFERENTIATOR.
KNOWLEDGE AND IP TENT.
NOW, THUS FAR HE JOE BIDEN'S
PEOPLE HAVE DENIED HE KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
DOJ IS SURELY GOING TO
INVESTIGATE THAT.
THERE'S NOTHING TO INDICATE TO
THE CONTRARY.
DONALD TRUMP HAS OPENLY ADMITTED
HE KNEW HE HAD THESE DOCUMENTS
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
HE'S OFFERED UP VARIOUS OTHER
DEFENSES.
SO HE CLEARLY KNEW.
THERE'S STILL A QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER HE HAD CRIMINAL INTENT.
THAT'S GOING TO BE CRUCIAL FOR
PROSECUTORS.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S
COMPLIANCE.
AS JAMIE JUST SAID, AS SOON AS
JOE BIDEN'S LAWYERS FOUND THIS
THEY NOTIFIED THE DOCUMENTS AND
TURNED OVER THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
OF COURSE DONALD TRUMP'S TEAM
WAS MUCH MORE RESISTANT AND IS
NOW BEING INVESTIGATED FOR
POTENTIAL OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> WELL, SPEAKING OF THAT
INVESTIGATION OF THE DOJ, ELIE,
HOW BIG OF A PROBLEM WILL THIS
BE FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND NOW?
>> HE'S GOT PROBLEMS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE COMPLICATED.
NOW, IMPORTANTLY, MERRICK
GARLAND HAS APPOINTED A U.S.
ATTORNEY NAMED JOHN LAUSCH THE
U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE CHICAGO
AREA.
HE'S ACTUALLY A TRUMP-APPOINTED
ATTORNEY.
TO INVESTIGATE THE BIDEN
DOCUMENTS.
AND WE JUST REPORTED EARLIER
TODAY THAT LAUSCH HAS ALREADY
GIVEN HIS PRELIMINARY REPORT TO
MERRICK GARLAND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
NOW, GARLAND HAS TWO CHOICES.
HE CAN SAY I SEE NOTHING HERE,
WE'RE CLOSING IT DOWN, OR HE CAN
SAY THERE MAY BE SOMETHING HERE,
LET'S LAUNCH A FULL-SCALE
INVESTIGATION.
OF COURSE WITH RESPECT TO
TRUMP'S DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO
MERRICK GARLAND HAS APPOINTED A
SPECIAL COUNSEL, JACK SMITH, WHO
IS INVESTIGATING BOTH THE
MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS AND DONALD
TRUMP'S INVOLVEMENT IN JANUARY
6th.
JACK SMITH IS GOING TO MAKE THE
INITIAL RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
WHETHER TO INDICT OR NOT.
BUT AGAIN, ULTIMATELY THE BUCK
STOPS WITH MERRICK GARLAND.
HE WILL HAVE THE FINAL SAY ON
BOTH OF THESE.
>> THAT'S THE LEGAL
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT ABOUT CONGRESS?
>> IT IS A DIFFERENT WORLD ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THE WORLD WE'VE GOTTEN USED TO
WITH SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AND
ADAM SCHIFF RUNNING SOME OF THE
KEY INVESTIGATIONS, THAT IS NOT
THE WORLD ANYMORE.
AS OF LAST WEEK WE NOW HAVE
SPEAKER McCARTHY.
JIM JORDAN WILL BE RUNNING SOME
OF THE KEY INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU KNOW THEY WILL DIG IN ON
THIS.
WE HAD REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS LAST NIGHT ON OUR AIR
TALKING ABOUT HOW EAGER THEY
WERE TO DIG INTO THIS.
WE HAVE A QUOTE HERE FROM
REPRESENTATIVE JAMES COMER FROM
THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WHO
SAID, "IS THE WHITE HOUSE GOING
TO BE RAIDED TONIGHT?
ARE THEY GOING TO RAID THE BIDEN
CENTER?"
THIS IS FURTHER CONCERN THAT
THERE IS A TWO-TIERED JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THERE'S SOME HYPERBOLE THERE.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, REPUBLICANS
WILL DIG IN.
THEY WILL MAKE A MEAL OF THIS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> MM-HMM.
ELIE, AS YOU KNOW, CNN JUST DID
THIS BIG RUDY SPECIAL OVER THE
WEEKEND.
IT WAS FASCINATING.
JUST INCREDIBLE TO REMEMBER HOW
LONG RUDY GIULIANI HAS BEEN A
PART OF OUR PUBLIC
CONSCIOUSNESS.
AND NOW HE SEEMS TO BE BACK IN
FOCUS.
WHAT'S THE LATEST?
>> YEAH, IT'S YET ANOTHER STEP
IN THE CONTINUING FALL OF RUDY
GIULIANI.
HE'S NOW BEEN SUBPOENAED BY THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, JACK SMITH,
PART OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
LOOKING FOR RECORDS RELATED TO
PAYMENTS THAT RUDY GIULIANI
RECEIVED FROM TRUMP-AFFILIATED
POLITICAL ENTITIES.
THIS TELLS US THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION IS
EXPANDING, IS GETTING INTO
FINANCIAL DETAILS.
AND OF COURSE WE REMEMBER THAT
DETAIL FROM THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE THAT RUDY GIULIANI AT
ONE POINT REQUESTED $20,000 PER
DAY FOR HIS LEGAL SERVICES.
AND SO